citizens of the reject Nation we and by
we I mean the real Aaron Alexander give
this man a follow are here to return for
the follow-up film Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Out of the Shadows now I know we
weren't the biggest fans of the prior
installment to this one we were not
the things we appreciated though right
there are things we appreciated about it
yeah yeah appreciate it a little bit
more than you I think well you know I
appreciate it I didn't I hate it I just
thought it was aggressively made these
are some things there's some nice things
for sure for sure the common thing that
I've heard people say is that the
follow-up this one is a better one so I
feel like we should watch it going with
an open mind and judge for ourselves if
we like it more than the last one we'll
see we just gotta be honest at the end
of the day we gotta be honest but ladies
and gentlemen what do you prefer this
one leave it down in the comments below
yes this is one of those things Aaron
has never seen this one I've never seen
this I'm pretty sure I did see this one
time
uh yes
I don't know the plot at all
yep don't know if I can give a slight
spoiler
but I feel like it's because I saw that
in a compilation of honest trailers that
there is a sky beam in this movie
the last one ripped off the Spider-Man
movie but this one's gonna rip off every
other comic book yeah we'll see well who
knows who knows who knows but ladies and
gentlemen we're after a great start
leave a like on this video thank you to
prepper for editing down these reaction
highlights and as always full
interaction watch long were you single
with your own copy of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Out of The Shadow
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page as always we
cover several things there exclusively
reaction highlights and watch Longs
included
let's get to it people
[Music]
did they do that in the first one I
don't think so no we got some ninja
stars in the opening okay I like that
off to a good start all right getting
creative it's better guys it's a better
movie
10 out of 10.
oh there they are then Turtles fellas
it's go time Turtles on the top
[Music]
what happened to Turtle formation I
thought you
said why would he say s what
yay we're starting with them yay
yeah cool
Donny here we go
that was a really fun opening I like
this this is a really fun opening yeah
man
steal it yeah
look how that delivery man is just used
to delivering the pizza that way gotta
show up at this corner every night let's
get that box from Mikey
that's a whole reintroduction right this
was a totally different tone what the
hell I love this
how are you guys not ruining the pizza
right
I feel like it's gonna get smushed
where's the cheese staying in place
of the bottom of that box what's going
on here
yes this already feels way more like the
turtles Right a million times better
instantly that's it's in the house right
here anyone can sit down there he saved
the city we should be on the Jumbo Tron
not in it what's the point Fair Point
rough along with his army of enforcers
the Foot Clan Shredder ruled our streets
until one day from out of the Shadows
stepped a Beacon of Hope who's gonna get
the credit
was just a humble cameraman oh this guy
no way
single-handedly battled Shredder locking
him up behind bars no what that's not
the Shredder from the first one later
this week we'll receive an honorary key
to the city
please welcome
oh what a bunch of wow you
changed man you changed you sold out bro
do the turtle's under the bus well the
truth is Jill I actually had helped a
couple of friends no way he's totally
gonna give his props no he's not he's
not thunder and lightning ah you suck
you know we couldn't take credit for
bringing down Shredder Vern's just
sticking to the arrangement we made with
him what's the point of doing something
if you don't get credit
I'm only in it for the glory god oh be
careful with that that's my pea shooter
you got to say
[Laughter]
an example
one minute
it's a ninja aim right you got this
[Laughter]
why is no one trying to wipe it off
right or telling him right at my grand
central station's taking out Dr Baxter
Stockman oh Baxter Stockman he graduated
MIT at 15 he's got 134 patents he's the
lead scientist for tcri Tyler Perry
I think Baxter Stockman is working
Shredder do you need us there no Baxter
is a softy she's like a spy right CIA
agent super spy I want to use it to join
hack into Baxter's emails your watch
needs to be within three feet of his
device iPad iPhone whatever
here you are sir
yeah I'm vibing with this one much more
already yeah instantly we'll see how it
goes but we're currently early currently
vibing with it better already yeah
you don't know who I am your back's just
documented truly inspirational for me
I'm so sorry I'm just like I'm a nerd no
please I'm a nerd she's got a Medea
fetish it's the difference between like
Lord of the Rings and Harry Potter or
um TED talks and Comic-Con
[Laughter]
at every step of the way
so I have to take this really quick it's
my boyfriend I'm sorry oh you have a
boyfriend
Halloween what's going on here
oh is she gonna do Action Hero change
okay Action Hero change put the yellow
jacket on I think she's jacking the
outfit she's just eyed right no she has
to put her she has to put her official
suit on okay it'll perfectly fit don't
worry
sure you take the wig off
okay school girl
yep
Jennifer's Body I was just thinking the
same thing
look everybody I got a cowboy
[Music]
I love how that guy just let his hat get
stolen right oh she's hot
oh wow
defense
don't let the pizza slide into the core
Mikey that's the last slice come on
[Laughter]
someone's gonna eat on that pizza
oh no way corniest piece on my Nike it's
Pizza look at it look at my shoe oh my
God it's a Nike advertisement he's on my
Nike hey man that's CGI slice I'm sorry
we're just gonna act like that's a
normal thing that happens in
professional basketball we're gonna have
to find a new spot to watch the game now
Mikey Mikey I mean they're not gonna
know for a show the stay of the Dead
David dead it's like the one night of
the year where we fit in Mikey we're
ninjas we live in the shadows let's go
let's go
I just really feel like that I'm not I'm
not just sitting here to say it the
personalities just feel a lot more
boisterous yeah yeah because they're
actually the leads of the movie this
time
and look how real that looks
[Music]
Transformers ah cool Baxter is working
with the Foot Clan Shredder is being
transported to a prison in Upstate New
York tonight and the Foot Clan are
planning on hitting the Convoy goddamn
foot Clint he'll be free again
who Donnie
tretter the shredder definitely getting
soft reboot Vibes out of this 100
because yeah they took themselves so
seriously and they're trying to be all
dark and gritty with that first one
rather than embracing it with like the
weird sci-fi Tech and like actually
casting an actor for Shredder this time
around
oh it's that oh the wrestler guy Sheamus
yes
[Music]
is this a different actor than the first
one it's 100 a different actor we never
even saw his face yeah we did remember
kind of like it was kind of it was in
the shadows but they're like oh we're
not too sure about this because they're
actually I read some oh this is so Arrow
what up big daddy lawbreaker he's the
people's champ of Sac right here
you have meditated for nearly 24 hours
in 10 seconds you will reach nirvana
does somebody want to explain
Sensei the Foot Clan are attempting to
make shredder out of custody the effects
look so much better especially on him
they read they did a remodel on on
Splinter there okay guys don't get too
excited it's still a work in progress
oh bumblebee
turtle tank
all these wires are still cool Tech
upgrade yeah with the sewer cap on top I
love that don't recline
neat Donatello actually doing some cool
inventions you got 32 counts of first
degree murder God damn you my friend
seriously need a hobby I myself am a
hockey guy ah
hey Mr Shredder big fan of your work
especially your Rarity stuff my name is
Bebop this is rocks
what works in mysterious ways donut
Shredder now you get to spend the rest
of your life behind bars or not I feel
like he's like pitching up his voice a
bit to sound like younger Stephen Amell
yeah definitely it's got a nicer guy
tone
coming up on our right and our left
come on man go go go go go go go
damn this feels like GI Joe
oh my god
oh cool that's pretty dope
man they really blew those cars up huh
for real that's some real destruction
right there
is an effective ass car chase
we're being ambushed heading north on 87
we need immediate backup
oh how fun I wouldn't want to
participate in a breakout Heist like
this come on
come on with the three-wheeled car
motorcycles come on this is awesome I'm
having a lot more fun yeah it's way more
fun
[Music]
we're the Shelf they're in the back what
the hell are they doing in the back
creating an obstacle for you I hope when
he said where were the shells that's
when the turtles show up I would have
liked that they're trying to make him a
little bit like Bruce Willis and die
hard try to make him John mcclainish I
can see that yeah you see it
ah the turtles they're the shells
[Music]
oh
my God sweet sauce that is deadly you
almost killed Casey right nunchucks
giganticus
it's like a serious Transformers
say hello to my little friend
pretty cool effects pretty cool facts
yeah
[Applause]
why not
guys they're coming back enough
it's time to take out the trash Turtle
style let's go let's go rap let's go
that's how I roll
that's how you roll
let's go
[Music]
ah surfing a motorcycle so awesome move
in Get Him to the extraction point
oh this is a well-constructed car chase
yeah it's a very entertaining yeah
action scene kinetic but I can keep up
with it too yeah exactly so everything's
going on it's not too muddled
[Applause]
how is that safe for him to be there
[Music]
he's so long to shoot right
good start work here look at this man
this is good right
I can't get over it I feel like they got
an entirely different creative team for
this one they must have we have to
teleport Shredder earlier but you said
yes
teleport Shredder I'm not gonna question
it
yeah we got that Tech now
knocking on one shot is all you got
to not miss your chance initiate take
the shot Mikey
yeah let's go full sci-fi I'm down
teleportation abilities
this is not very realistic for my
Turtles movie
that's right yes I remember that now yep
that's yes
oh my God I don't remember looking this
disturbing oh of all the ways you guys
excuse me but that would require you I'm
thinking me and no one no thing is
smarter than the cry I do not remember
this design at all
it's so slimy you had your buddy Dr
Stockman found something of mine oh my
God it's so gross upon entering your
atmosphere it broke apart into three
pieces
sweet another is in a museum in New York
of course it is
Rainforest and rainforests it's a museum
two locations
it will open a portal through which I
could bring my War Machine the Tetra
drone to Earth okay okay this is
definitely an early 2010s plot oh yeah
what is he he's like he's an alien right
problems with those pests
oh
look back in
oh his eyeball I popped out of it
I do like how uncomfortably disturbing
it's real ripples
[Laughter]
it's all slimy and like drippy too yeah
kind of residue from a teleportation
event yeah teleportation event residue
man it's the worst
totally Plug and Play perfect I'll go
check it out we'll go with our brain
support even the Turtle sewer Hideout is
brighter and when hourly updates from
Homeland Security and border patrol make
it on the half hour excuse me this is my
investigation now
bureau chief Vincent organized crime
sweet
two female lead detectives
this movie was woke before woke existed
[Laughter]
ninjas on motorcycles just they come
zipping past and they're coming at us
Giant
it's taking me a long time to get
acclimated to his performance
you're so used to seeing him as like
arrows
you're so goofy thanks for your
statement Jones that's officer Jones
and I'm gonna be a detective someday
what did you say
well they Infuse the hockey element of
Casey into this I hope so
so you two idiots have a favorite bar
you don't have to be stupid enough to go
back there
yeah they will of course they will yeah
they are
my man my man did they not mutate in
this movie do you know I think they do
yo guys how special I love this guy that
time
a side of pickles no are these pickles
untraceable those phones are hard to
track and Shredder himself oh he looks
familiar he's in 30 Rock in Brooklyn
Nine-Nine and John Wick I'm tired of
being someone else's errand boy maybe
even start our own foot plan I mean
honestly how hard could it be
sweet shot yeah
oh my God gone with the mecca suit
thank God he's not looking for partners
I'm looking for Aaron Moore's
we could work with that
I'm looking for turtles
also I feel like the music tracks in
this fit track way better yeah the last
one they kind of felt a little forced at
times this actually Vibes well with the
movie tapped it well to the the vibe of
the scenes I agree do not let this
setback distract you as long as you keep
the team Unified
you shall always succeed that's the
lesson you sure those guys didn't come
through here hey Bill I don't know what
you're talking about drinking on the job
I love this song
and listen
hey what are you doing uh you know what
never mind it has a scratch on it damn
it holy crap look at the skills of this
guy I slipped them cell phones that's
all I know and I imagine a responsible
business person wouldn't sell Hardware
without a means by which to track I have
a GPS this guy's cave again so easily
right I just realized the Vanilla Ice
thing is a it's a fun Easter egg because
Vanilla Ice is in the second 90s movie
yeah
you did uh go ninja yeah
I feel like if I saw Megan Fox in person
I would explode
[Laughter]
spontaneously combusted which doesn't
happen I know just just freak out like I
would be like
those four brothers are still out there
we need to create soldiers that could
defeat them with a single blow and this
will help us do that guy shredder
actually has a personal fear against the
turtles stopping him yes
I completely thought Shredder was not in
this movie
um yeah yeah I had no clue
foreign
but I like that he's actually a person
in this one yeah because I feel like
this one like outside the Wilderness
thing I don't think you need to watch
the first one to get this one deal with
this
this is when they be okay this makes
sense yeah I'm Gonna Keep Them human
they know what the people want
that's things not in a good way
ah
whoa trippy visual
all right
oh mutation mutation the key to our
Evolution I wonder if they always start
off as people
are you or most of the time whoa
[Music]
this is like a body horror
transformation dude
wow man it's like full-on horror movie
monster transformation
this feels funny
aren't your clothes like just rip off at
that point Let's Get Like You Gotta Get
Like mutant sized clothes for you okay
if the hole can keep it on man they can
you're not wrong about that I knew it
it is a really smart cop
inside every human there's a dormant
Gene which ties us to our animal
ancestors you're a rhinoceros and you're
a I don't know what you were warthog
[Laughter]
O'Neill
get that canister
oh smooth sliding
foreign
yeah get that mask on
this really does look like the GI Joe's
movies too with the black and leather
and stuff yeah I see it whoa whoa
you guys don't really wanna
do this again right it doesn't usually
work out well you should have given the
turtles a heads up at the turtle alarms
oh he's using the hockey pucks instead
of the guns that he probably owns as a
cop
no why is he resorting to this side
because fan service
bad hockey stick is really strong
oh
where'd it go
[Laughter]
that was funny
[Applause]
I'm having fun with the KC inclusion
simultaneously is one of the things I
feel the most tempted to criticize
it doesn't exactly make sense it's not
Dragon yeah
Casey Jones
hey well
do not eat us
[Laughter]
they're my friends yeah Donatello over
there and the purple he's a technical
genius who is technically
Raphael over there in the red he's like
a big cuddly teddy bear he's in the blue
fearless leader silent but deadly and
I'm at glance take a laugh track I love
this music with it
you have eyes on Bebop and Rocksteady
what do you care about those two well
let's just say that I have a vested
interest in bringing them to justice
grab Friday the 13th here at follow nice
nice
laughs
yeah we've uh seen them around here
before
gotta go hard leaving you Casey Jones
it's all you bro
[Laughter]
giant rat one new guy zero
you know I was doing just fine tracking
Bebop and Rocksteady and then you just
T-boned my existence it doesn't make
sense why this version of him would have
a mask
you have a gun
you go up against these ninjas
[Laughter]
who are these guys
these four have done more for this city
than you will ever know where they will
ever take credit for they have not
failed this city
the canister of purple loses at Police
Headquarters I'm bringing with me the
next generation of finely tuned combat
soldiers
oh disgusting I've never been the
biggest beep bop and Rocksteady
a little goofy if the purple ooze can
turn humans into animals if properly
re-engineered watch this watch this
oh you could turn them into humans it
could turn us
humans
change back no man you gotta Embrace who
you are we don't need that kind of
change okay you're right we're American
Heroes they do look a lot better this
time around I know they feel like real
characters too yeah you can't say a word
of this to the others
all the ones would be eavesdropping oh
my God it's gonna be a story of
acceptance Embrace who you are it all
started with the big bang well I got a
big bang for you
that is the worst that's what we do
to be honest they're a little Annoying I
mean
is there characters is it
some of the designs do have this 90s
aesthetic that I like
you don't have to be stuck down here
forever you know so Leo told Donnie to
keep it a secret
uh no hold on you didn't
you didn't answer what are the three
most important traits to the ninja speed
stealth
trust and honor
where's the honor and keeping secrets
from your brothers oh we just resolved
this immediately okay we're addressing I
don't know what you're talking about wow
so now you're adding lion to the list
it's called compartmentalization of
information
well Justified
if there's even a chance that ooze can
make us human it's about what people up
there are willing to accept true
acceptance only comes from within damn
he's an actual like leader
and what about Mikey he don't get a vote
there's only one vote that counts in
this family mine that's not a real
leader he's gonna have to
have to right there man you benching me
call it what you want what did I do
sorry guys Turtle division from the data
I just collected I'm surmising that what
was inside this thing may help Shredder
open that portal to another dimension
[Laughter]
Thanos we can take the elevator shafts
and vents we need you two to stay on the
ground I can't just walk right into
Police Headquarters what are you chicken
what are you calling chicken turtle
such an insult so we're breaking into
police headquarters
we need to find someone to sneak you
guys past I'm sorry this performance is
so weird
I don't quite like quite get what he's
doing
am I just too familiar with like him and
interviews and on Arrow because
something about it feels so artificial
[Laughter]
feel real to me
we need to find Shredder I don't know
we're not doing I got concerts
it's just the city I'm still trying to
figure out what Casey's like role is in
this like what is he adding to this
equation that like the turtles couldn't
do themselves all right I think we'll
find out via this plan thank you for
doing this stuff think about what the
city means to all of us
I do like how Donatello's spy Tech is
really coming to play I'm now Mikey
you're marrying them hurrying
[Music]
I'm starting to feel like the focus is
going a little all over the place
it's a cowboy
Mikey will be right there
all the cops here both parties
gotta be a normal and it's heading
toward the front door
all the ninjas feel like Snake Eyes
right no seriously
sweet The Boys Are Back wait we're the
good guys
why are you afraid of getting a shot I
thought you guys are bulletproof they're
monsters they're not monsters
don't you go
oh
awesome awesome Jones you gotta be
kidding me you know the monsters are the
greatest threat to America
I can't get them all on the same page to
think with one mind you shouldn't want
them all to think the same it's their
different points of view that make the
team strong oh my God and Splinter's
mentoring good leader guys a good
brother accepts it yes I thought this
movie was a minor Improvement this is a
major step up right in everywhere
this is an actual Ninja Turtles yeah
even if I didn't have any familiar with
turtles before it's such it's a much
more enjoyable film it looks like our
mutant buddies are headed to Brazil how
do we get there we sneak onto the next
cargo plane from JFK you know of a
turtle plane
that's not what happened we checked its
authenticity oh
you should be chasing
there are times where he just slips
right into his Oliver Queen performance
oh yeah because that super important
thing you kind of fire thing to find and
we are ready by action
bye
they're unusually cartoony
yeah we only have a 30 second window you
know the plan
I don't need to shoot I got my balls
I like how the tough ones one is afraid
I cannot get over how much better the
visual effects are it's much more
seamless at times it looks like
practical effects much more seamless and
the way that the action scenes are
constructed it's a lot more yeah
visually palatable what would Vin Diesel
do look at that literally thinking to
myself too like this is so fat it's a
fast and furious vibes
[Laughter]
faster
somebody kind of fast
you're gonna make it okay
is that Brian Tyree Henry uh I don't
think so oh I think that was him
the good news is you're wearing shoes
the bad news is
I am finding myself though starting to
Crave some of the hand-to-hand martial
arts choreography that the first one
offered that's been kind of missing I
feel that way definitely over an hour
into this movie maybe in the the finale
what's going on here
[Music]
oh my God he said these morons
they're alive
everything is great I'm doing awesome
why are you trying to still Land This
Plane just evacuate it I don't have
parachutes
oh we're staying in there okay
[Music]
this is insane there's some great shots
though the way they transitioned in and
out of like playing disguise is really
well done
oh my God
what turtle in water
everyone okay wait where's Raph
got even the flesh
look at the texture and the Flesh on his
arm it just looks so real yeah with the
water yeah
[Applause]
sweet sauce finally
Hot Potato Hot Potato
[Music]
characters in movies always find
themselves in these crazy waterfalls
[Music]
yeah that's awesome real team effort
Leo quit being man they all tried their
best they were all improvising I don't
the situation they didn't anticipation
Mr Stockman doctored the footage
so I'm betting that there's some sort of
action Dairy feed that will show that
he's been working with shredder I want
you to be the hero that the whole city
thinks you are
just hang up enough this
hidden camera bingo
okay
he's actually starting to feel essential
because there is a point where I was
like I feel like it was sort of
perfunctory that they were like we have
to we have to put him in here
their hacking abilities are phenomenal
once it's fully powered the portal will
be just wide enough for the Techno drone
to come through piece by piece this is
gonna be insane
he seems like he's having fun
is that what I think it is there it is
[Laughter]
alien warship is coming through piece by
piece whoa interesting oh is it
assembling commanding officer goes by
the name of
I don't know that guy but I hate that
guy
we may be the only ones who can survive
around that portal the only ones who can
get close enough to this Technodrome to
shut it down it's like you were born for
this
[Laughter]
one sip
and we'll stay the same on the inside
but look like humans on the outside no
they're not gonna take it are they I
take it I take anything
I'm desperate for drugs I take one that
turns me into a turtle
I'll do whatever you guys say but uh
only Ralph gets the vote
[Laughter]
there you go
oh out of the Shadows oh yeah
[Laughter]
let's just say we're Four Brothers From
New York who hate bullies and love this
city nice and right now we're the city's
best hope we're teenagers we're
teenagers bacon egg and cheese tell her
about the arrangement confess
these are your confessions these four
are the ones who took Shredder down the
first time I was kind of more of a
wingman we've been doing our part to
protect this city from the Shadows now
we're out of the Shadows into the light
we're gonna need strategy Instinct oh
this is cool
awesome
for the finale
of the last one this is awesome I'll be
a god
you'll be just what you've always been a
fly
a footnote Oh Oh I thought you were
gonna say anything yeah
no one will ever know who you are
wow Shredder no honor this is like a
soft reboot does he have the the mecca
now he's just regular as an actual
outfit this time
Death Star
Unicron whoa this is a super
Transformers right now
oh god oh this guy is so gross I imagine
this had to be in 3D when it came out in
theater I think so yeah the beacon has
been set and once the Techno drone
reassembles we can rule the planet did
they put black yeah on his face yeah I
do not like to share you betrayed me
actually I barely even thought about you
yeah
yeah oh wow what oh that's upsetting
that's lame he's been such a passive
villain this whole movie
oh wow oh my God wait slow down there's
probably Easter eggs there oh
no
damn you can feel that all right is
April's makeup intact just tell me
April's makeup is intact let me know
she's okay oh my God she's so hot thank
you but she's still hot it's got a
worried for a second damn oh it's
perfect it's okay she's looking right at
me oh my God does she want me
should I leave
[Music]
it's not that bad it's just a dumb robot
there's like some post-apocalyptic
cyberpunk sci-fi Vibe about it hey
Bubblicious let's see what you've got
they've replaced Mecca Shredder with
Craig about 90 seconds before this thing
is complete
all you Donny you know I'm looking
forward to enslaving you we're turtles
not tortoises
yeah Turtles fight
you don't think I've got plans for this
yeah
it says
much cooler actions we'll say
wow how would Casey possibly beat them
that's death that's a concussion
he's Oliver Queen
[Laughter]
he's gonna save this did you just see
rollerblade oh okay
he needs rollerblades
prepare to watch your city
I got it I found the beacon up
[Music]
there oh I'll get that Beacon yeah
wow
yeah this is definitely a 3D movie
actually seems great that he has
rollerblades
oh stop stop
would that hurt them how you think not
right let me give you a hug
goodbye
kiss him give him a little smooch
they're working together
where's Mikey nice nice
praying is down but his ship's still
building
uh oh I do got some issues with the
handling of crying over all that I
wouldn't dive into after the movie but
definitely got some criticisms
close the portal now
way to go Casey
we did it
kind of looks like the timeline from uh
from Loki a little bit I'll be back
a thousand times stronger no you won't
this is the last one it didn't make
enough money
it bombed we got something no one else
has
garbage truck
strong arms
Turtle bodies
oh yeah that yeah they got that Cape
convicts Bebop and Rocksteady are now in
police custody while Dr Baxter Stockman
remains oh
and I guess Shredder is just in with
their ship with another dimension how
did they arrest be pop in Rock City I
present to you the keys to the city a
symbol of our appreciation respect and
for our continued partnership but don't
you dare come out to the light
stay in there
water yes freak I think you should give
people more credit I think we'll stick
with the arrangement we've had if you
ever need us April knows where to find
us you guys can sign autographs at
Comic-Con now
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not putting a shot it's not easy
putting a shot like that together the
visuals in here are so much better oh
same year as Civil War did it yeah
and they're tired it's a Teenage Ninja
Ninja Turtles turtles in a half shell
turtle power
well all right
is there a post-credits scene oh wait if
there is a post-credit scene this one
you raise you see it I'll remember all
right I might we'll see all right okay
let's see how it goes
um well yeah man yeah uh let's uh
let's Chit Chat Molly's credits are
rolling what'd you think man I thought
that was a lot of fun yeah I had a
really good time with it I know there's
a lot of people not happy that we didn't
like the first one but I can genuinely
say I enjoyed this one
ratio hell yeah so out of authenticity
all those views it's still like only
three percent really four percent we
really had a real issue with us okay
it's the vocal ones all right yeah
that's fine yeah that's fine all right
oh God that was creepy that was a weird
Stephen Amell drawing right there I
enjoyed this one significantly more yeah
and I feel like the reaction uh during
their you know because sometimes there's
so much dialogue happening that there
are other thoughts that I want to get
out but
part of the thing is like finding the
right spot to give the the additional
thoughts uh I really I could there I did
have some criticisms though but I feel
like the compliments about this movie I
feel like I made pretty clear
um because yeah the the directing of it
just the directing and the
cinematography was a much more appealing
aesthetic all around to just actually
take in not easy to follow the last one
had uh this weird you know
grimy blend of trying to look gritty
realistic and it just ultimately left
for like a uh kind of a dour tone or
something like it was never never really
approached naturally fun whereas this
right off the bat
had a much better pace and an energy and
felt authentically fun like I want to do
my best to remove myself from what uh
you know over to Ninja Turtles movie
should be and just go with like is this
a decent movie or not you know and I
felt that this ultimately was a decent
movie and especially when you compared
to the last one it's it's a significant
Improvement because even if you just
look at it as its own film
the things they talk about in the
previous one that are like kind of just
throw away lines are not really fleshed
out where it comes to Ralph's anger they
even talk about Leo you're the leader I
never really got that sense in the last
one you know
um them as a family and all these all
the things that they talk about that
they're kind of just throw away lines
their actual plot points here in
character development for everyone so
just as a film it's it's a much better
movie not everything about it that I
really love
um and there are a couple of things
really just one thing in particular that
I preferred in the first one
um but yeah those are like my my general
thoughts on it and
what did you think about
praying
I thought Krang was
visually interesting you know he's like
they made an effort to make him like
really grotesque and slimy but I think
ultimately at the end of the day he was
just a physical foil for them to fight
yeah because they didn't really flesh
him out he was literally in one scene in
the beginning and then the end fight and
that was it and the Turtles only just
learned about him like a couple minutes
before they find him right right yeah so
it's not this active threat that they're
trying to work to to stop it's just like
oh this is what's happening okay now we
have to engage with this threat that we
just learned about so there's no
personal connection towards it and they
just are like we have to stop it because
we're heroes and we're Turtles and
that's what we do which is my problem
with the shredder fight in the last
movie yeah there's no personal Stakes
involved yeah those were it's like they
just have to fight Shredder and Shredder
is kind of personality Less in in the
last one also the turtles never see
Shredder directly in this one
really yeah I don't think they saw him
once on the freeway
I think yeah though uh I would have just
been fine with a rematch instead of
instead of this crank like the crane
fight felt very Transformers and had
that Vibe of you know the the wash
together visuals of a bunch of the of
the color palette of the scene but it
still looked pretty cool like I was I
was surprised how I was actually
enjoying that sequence because normally
the way the the color aesthetic was
would kind of put me off but that scene
still had the I like the shutter speed
the motion effect that they had a lot of
those locked off shots like the POV with
uh Michelangelo skateboarding and
whatnot so there's still some cool
visuals and a lot of it kind of did feel
like it was plucked out of an anime and
and I and I think uh crane does look
cool but man the second they uh froze
incapacitated Shredder I was like dad's
a lame ass move they actually had a
genuine build up to this they had a real
thing and they just gave him his help
they literally just gave him his help
he looked surprisingly cool too and then
immediately gonna freeze him and shovel
like that was they didn't think
that through that was total
yeah I will say even though I wasn't
personally invested in the stakes of the
Turtles versus crane sure I will say I
liked that
it was it wasn't about necessarily
Turtles versus crane but more so their
relationship with each other working
together to stop this common threat and
then coming together in that Arc which
is something I enjoyed yeah there's an
actual Arc here with them you know I
think they definitely swapped out the
screen time that they gave April on the
last one to actually give to the turtles
because she is definitely relegated to
being just a supporting character 100
like nowhere near as any of this a
personal Journey for her whatsoever
strictly to service the turtles like if
you know I almost forgot she was a
reporter until that thing is yeah yeah
sure like while I uh like I actually I
appreciated the efforts of the first
movie doing that
um not like it was like my favorite
thing in the world like I said a more
appreciated the efforts and I like
making Fox and I think that she plays
off well with these guys
um so yeah that was that was good crank
thing out of the way
uh the yeah yeah the train thing
definitely needs some improvement that
was that was my biggest uh thing that I
wanted to harp on okay
I enjoy as a controversial of a figure
Stephen Amell loves to put himself
the his performance here
I could not quite pinpoint what was so
odd about it and I couldn't tell if it
was just my own like subjective
I mean it is all subjective but I
couldn't tell if it was just
what I I I'm normally pretty good at
divorcing myself from another actor's
work even if I'm very accustomed to a
performance that I saw them do for a
very long time I I can I can definitely
appreciate the differences and nuances
of a completely different character yeah
and here it just didn't ring sincere to
me at any point uh with what he was
doing with his with his voice and
mannerisms and his never blinking that
he loves to carry I mean I think I think
that is just Stephen Amell I never
noticed he's not much of a blinker
um which works for like you know stoic
serious guy you know
um but here it was it was odd and I and
I don't really like the character that
much
this is where it's going to sound
strange logically I don't like the
character that much like in here there
is something weirdly fun about his
performance even though I can you know
intellectualize that there's so much
wrong about this portrayal uh we we
talked about it quite a bit the whole
thing with yeah like hockey players
they're just like force in here just
like because they have to work at home
this is Casey Jones so we gotta have it
it's it's bizarre
um when he's like fighting the ninjas I
hate that he whooped their asses
um that really upset me yeah I should
have pointed that out right away because
I was sort of waiting to see how things
would unfold but that severely undercuts
the threat of them and I probably would
have liked Casey Moore if he actually
struggled to fight them yeah versus
going in and weapons The Mask he got
beaten thrown into a car and didn't
affect him like in the slime he's a
superhuman he's all over Queen and he's
supposed to be the antithesis to that
yeah he's just like your regular Schmo
like your regular guy you know yeah yeah
I think that
I don't think he bothered me like he he
did bother me I don't know to the extent
of that you were bothered but I think it
was
I don't know I recognize he was trying
to do a different performance with uh
him pitching up his voice but yeah I
don't think it worked per se but I can
appreciate his his energy that he
brought to the film though
I don't know he didn't feel entirely
necessary if everything about his
character felt obligatory yeah like he's
just like oh we gotta have him because
that's what Ninja Turtles has Casey
Jones even though they're gonna put
Casey Jones and not really making Casey
Jones yeah but
you know it was it was fine also the the
kind of half-assed half-baked a romance
tease with him and April O'Neil oh
they're both hot they're both hot so
they got to get together yeah that's
what they do in the other properties and
they got to do it what happened to his
art to get respect from his peers yet is
it gonna make him detective after
helping save the world probably not or
she's just gonna go play hockey full-on
vigilante nothing happened there and he
wore it one time I'm like what was the
point I don't know why I changed into
that yeah it didn't because nothing
about outside of him physically doing it
had anything to do with his character
yeah
I was like that's I don't know it was
kind of lame it was lame it was a little
lame
um
the Bebop and Rocksteady they're
supposed to be juvenile I thought they
were annoying of course they were I I've
never really I've never really loved
Bebop and Rocksteady there's nothing
I've ever seen them in I've never read
it I've never read a Ninja Turtles comic
but like saying the cartoon
the secret of the actually I prefer kind
of their Secret of the Ooze portrayal
order they can't talk uh but yeah I I
don't know I've never I've never
personally been that gravitated towards
them it's weird because obviously crying
a CGI the turtles of CGI and they're CGI
but they're the only part to me that
felt like cartoons
I mean crane kind of felt a little
cartoony uh Baxter Stockman did too he
was kind of cartoon he reminded me of um
what's his name
um Electro
I wonder why like I don't get why they
didn't turn him into the fly they should
have turned them in they were sending
that this was definitely a setup movie
for a bigger Universe film yeah and I
never got why they call I called him
Sensei as if he like trained him to
fight that's what you call him I guess
so called Mr Shredder Mr Shredder yeah
doctor Shredder Doctor Who I would call
him doctor he's a doctor and say
shredder there's a nice ring to it yeah
I don't know what he does with his time
you know it's been two years since the
last one
he went on uh master class and like got
his Doctrine they can do that yeah
they're a little frustrating they still
look good though I like their
monstrosity I actually I was enjoying
them before they became the mutants yeah
when they were humans I was enjoying
them yeah I thought his look was very
80s prior to
uh was it Bebop that's the purple one
right
I think so oh man they're always a
pair I don't know man I forget the name
assignments all the time yeah yeah
that's what I forget it's because
they're always they're always together
and I and I constantly forget which
one's Bebop and Rock City again uh
yeah I don't recall well yeah well I
think that
I don't know they were they were fine I
guess they didn't really add much to the
story but you know I think that
they looked okay
also the lift didn't bother me as much
this time on the turtles I think they
toned the lips down they improved the
effects all around on the turtles yeah
they looked more real
um I think they did kind of I think they
leaned out Donatello a little bit yeah
he looked very lean that's that's
something I also picked up on this one
because they were through the turtles
were the leads and because they got a
lot more screen time I think that
in addition to their their looks their
personalities were also came a lot more
distinct well they've done this one
their expressions looked more believable
their textures were felt more tangible
there were times where it would look
like practical effects versus just mocha
whereas like in the last one it always
looked like complete CGI to me yeah they
only looked good when they were together
in the scenes by themselves but this
time they Blended well with their
environment and they could be in like
right as daylight in the sky yeah you
know full exposure to the Sun and they
look great yeah
um so I thought that was a a market
Improvement I do think like while and I
thought Leonardo actually was a felt
like a real character here there are
things about like the the pacing and the
overall cacophony of visual stimuli and
noise that can sometimes drown out some
of the emotion that the movie is going
for for sure uh but it bothered me more
on the first one though
that's I feel like I would have more
gripes with this movie if I didn't just
watch the last one
but this is such an improvement to me
that I appreciate it so much more
because
I I took a lot of fault with the last
one that that I'm like no other things
here where I'm like yeah the emotion
definitely could have rang a lot bigger
the comedy could have worked better
Michelangelo
um was sometimes too dumb to me okay I
feel that sometimes most of the time
he's really dumb though you know he's
supposed to be dumb but when Raphael's
like here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna go in and do this and
Michelangelo's like wait we're gonna we
have a plan we're gonna go do something
I don't get it but he's like all
sometimes the things were
like he was too dumb to me okay wasn't
reasonably
because again he's supposed to be the
dumb one he's supposed to be the Cloudy
head one supposed to be the Airhead uh
and the stoner one of the group yeah um
sometimes it was like
the I don't know I also I could have
used more uh more splinter in the movie
he they use him very sparingly and I
think he looked a lot better than he did
in the other one because I feel like he
had like it was just like skin and then
hair yeah like he looks like he grew his
hair out he was on some uh some hair
club on this one what I what I will say
that I did really and I did point it out
but I really did miss I thought the
martial arts of the first one was pretty
awesome I can agree with that and it is
almost completely absent here a lot like
a lot of time it does if when it's here
it doesn't shine and it's there's barely
there especially it was just kind of
weird to consider that they have
markedly more ninjas this time around uh
but they didn't feel at all like ninjas
yeah they didn't put them in scenarios
two B ninjas and also they didn't yes
they didn't try to heighten their
freakishly enormous strength this time
around well just their hand to hang the
fights are like not there you know like
there's no like as while I enjoyed the
the visual big the set pieces a lot here
especially uh yeah I enjoyed the I
enjoyed the set pieces a lot
like I I think you can call Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles like you you kind
of need the ninja aspect of them and
it's not here and that's the biggest
that's the one thing I'm like oh if you
just had like the actual Marsh Casey
Jones got to do more martial arts
choreography than they did yeah and
that's a real disappointing part to me
because that was the only thing that was
really missing to me and I I like the I
like the punches and the kicks of the
last one quite a bit uh even when
because when the movie wasn't working
for me that and the last one that was
really working for me and I don't know
why they completely eliminated that here
um but yeah I wish that was here still
though I mean I'd still take this movie
any day over the last one I could I
could watch this movie and enjoy it it's
it's genuinely fun has a good heart
um the color the the whole visual appeal
is is so much something more that I
personally just gravitate towards much
more and other than some disappointing
choices that they made I thought overall
was a market Improvement and a right
direction for something that ultimately
didn't pan out yeah yeah it sucks
because yeah the last one the first one
was so poorly received that no one
showed up for the second one and after
watching this one I'm like sadly I would
have watched one I would have never been
changed a direction like yeah I'd be
down for a third movie see where they go
I kind of wish I would have saw this in
3D because I feel like they really put
an effort into like making
three-dimensional yeah and I'm like yeah
I'm going to have been curious to see
what they look like in theaters but I
didn't go on to see it because I didn't
care at the time but I care now and I'm
sad we won't get a third one but hey we
got new Turtles now and they're better
yeah that's what I hear
ladies and gentlemen what did you think
about this movie do you prefer it over
the first leave your thoughts down below
did you wish we got a third subscribe
leave a like and Hey listen to the
patreon
Lance door they talk about the turtles
being heroes in a half show well you are
a full show my friend because Lance
store is a real life hero he's a
firefighter he goes out there and he
saves lives daily
sometimes he just breaks into people's
homes evacuates them even if there's not
a fire once in a while toaster might go
off oh overcook The Bagel a little too
long smoke hit the fire alarm mom walks
in the kitchen goes oh let me just fan
this out a little bit boom land store
breaks that door in with an ax goes
we're getting you the hell out of here
lady happens all the time there's been a
lot of reports about people wanting to
fire Lance a lot of the city in the part
of Canada that lives have personally
requested to their mayor that they
remove him from participating in the law
enforcement of being a firefighter yet
Lance remains because even once he was
fired once he was terminated from being
a firefighter he found a way to hide
inside the firefighting station so he
could still perch his way onto the back
of the firefighting trucks and
participate
whenever there's a cat in a tree that
the firefighters have to set up a ladder
for to go take them take the cat off
there's Lance with a hose to shoot that
cat down with a big blast of water many
cats have died and Canada due to Lance's
overreaching willingness to be a hero
but
yeah
thanks Lance
[Music]